(audience applauds)
- Good afternoon, everyone.
So let me tell you a story.
We've all just now finished Thanksgiving.
You remember that evening after,
you're crawling into bed full
of Turkey stuffing and stuffed
and falling asleep, absolutely cashed out.
And there's that little buzz that starts
to, like, wake you from sleep.
And it gets louder and it
gets louder and it's an alarm
and you wake up and you look at your phone
and it's a page and it says,
"Engineering response needed."
It's 2:00 AM. How many of you
guys have been there before?
Same.
So you think about this,
there's a customer that
called that, right?
Latencies doubled.
Their requests are dropped.
And the customer is furious.
And now you're online, sleep deprived,
desperately trying to figure
out what happened and why.
We've all been there
or have enough experience
to know about that.
We're gonna talk about the
groggy engineer today. (chuckles)
And we're gonna talk about
finding the noisy neighbor
customer performance patterns at scale.
I'm Nick Hefty, I've been at
Zendesk seven and a half years
and I've worked in the customer support
portion of the company
and moved over to software engineering.
So I've kind of got a
unique bridge between
being the one that calls that incident
and now occasionally one
that jumps on those incidents
to try to help see what's going on.
And I'm gonna talk
through a little bit today
about how Zendesk's journey
through observability
has found a way that we
can give the engineers
a little bit more rest.
So I'm gonna step away
from that for a second.
We are at re:Invent.
Let me briefly tell you
about some of the AWS stuff we have
just as I go through all of this.
We're an Aurora shop.
We use ElastiCache, EC2 instances,
a potted infrastructure,
and we heavily leverage AWS.
We are an AWS partner
and we really, really do
like working with them.
They're fantastic.
We moved from self-hosted to AWS,
a big reason being scalability,
and they're very good for that.
But we've got hundreds of
thousands of customers.
That leads to challenges.
How many of you have an infrastructure map
that looks like that? (chuckles)
High cardinality.
Because we have so many,
oh, back up, cardinality,
a whole bunch of stuff at the same level.
High cardinality being
a lot of those things
at that same level that
you're trying to look at.
Just so that we're all caught up.
We have high cardinality
and we struggle with
that from time to time.
We're trying to look at
parts of an infrastructure
that a small subset of
customers are interacting with
and we need to be able to figure out
when one of those goes sideways,
what we can do to help the customer
and protect those other customers
on a shared infrastructure.
And solving a problem for high cardinality
comes with a bunch of other challenges,
cost being one of them.
So, it's extremely high level. (chuckles)
Kubernetes infrastructure for us.
And we need
to balance out those loads
across our infrastructure
for all of those customers on our shards.
So when you're thinking about
managing for high cardinality,
I promise I will get back to
the noisy neighbor in a minute,
but I gotta set the stage,
balancing for that,
you need to look at what things
it explodes along with
those hundreds of thousands of customers.
So how can you mitigate
some of this retention?
How long you retain what you're seeing,
how much you sample of all of that, right?
Is it a process that you
really need to see a lot of,
or is it just something that
you want to track over time
and is 1% enough?
And data sensitivity,
is this something that's a security risk?
You need to capture all of it?
Is this something that is a process,
again, you need to track over time?
And so we've all been in a situation
similar to this
where you're balancing
cost and observability.
It's kind of a big teeter-totter, right?
And the more you engage with it,
sometimes the scarier it is.
I'm hoping I can tell you a little bit
of our journey through that
and make it a little bit
less scary and frustrating.
A wise engineer learns
from their own mistakes.
It takes a fool not to learn
from the mistakes of others.
Hopefully I can tell
you some of my mistakes
(chuckles) and you can take those away
so you don't make them yourself.
So one more piece of
things to set the stage.
What is a noisy neighbor?
Max did a great job of
describing this initially,
but I'm gonna use an apartment complex
kind of descriptor here
and we'll talk through it
a little in that sense.
So a noisy neighbor
is, just like Max said,
the hotel neighbor, the upstairs neighbor
that's causing noise,
keeping you from sleep,
we will come back to sleep a couple times,
but keeping you from sleep.
And they're affecting everybody
else that's around them.
That apartment complex is a
shared piece of infrastructure.
It's the thing that everybody is using
and one person is messing
it up for everybody else.
Back to our groggy engineer.
Jump into that incident.
And this is what you see.
This is the customer traffic pattern.
Yeah, it doesn't tell you
a lot, does it? (laughs)
It's pretty straightforward
that they're hitting an end point.
Well, we kind of knew that already.
But a lot of times, this is
how observability starts.
You don't know what you need to see
until you suddenly need to see it.
And the worst time to
suddenly need to see it
is your under-caffeinated brain
woken up from a deep sleep.
It's worst time to troubleshoot.
So we started to solve that
by tagging across our tenants.
Tenants.
Go back to the analogy I
used of apartment complex,
tenants are the buildings,
the people in those buildings.
And if we're just showing
that previous image
of just that one part of the call,
I have no idea where
resources are being starved.
traffic is coming from
to be able to see why the
customer's having the problem
that they're having.
But if I start early on by tagging
some of that infrastructure,
when I wake up in the morning
or get woken up in the morning,
I now can see something like this.
This is APM traces from Datadog,
and they helped
develop tracing alongside Zendesk,
was for a lot of use cases we had.
It's fantastic.
But it allows us to tag every
step of that infrastructure.
Same call.
Look at all what I can see.
So much more.
So let me talk you through
a process that we use
to try to go through this,
to try to iterate on
what I just showed you.
Now, adding tags to tenants,
but that's not the only way
to see more information.
The first part is recognize.
What do you see or need to see?
Do I need to see hot partitions?
Do I need to watch our backlogs?
Do I need to see latency spikes?
So we can do that in
multiple different ways.
We can look at APM,
that application performance
monitoring I mentioned before.
But we can also look at things like logs,
infrastructure monitoring and metrics.
Excuse me.
All of that allows us
to use different vehicles
to recognize the thing
that's causing the problem.
Now, we need to examine that.
So, great, woke up in the morning,
had to solve the incident,
couldn't see what I wanted to see.
Okay, what did I need to see?
Recognize what you needed to see.
Now, let's examine that.
Let's figure out how
to be able to see that.
Do we need to see top tenants?
Do we need to tag those tenants
like I showed initially?
Is one of the issues that cardinality
that we're running into at that level.
Do we have a bunch of
microservices, you know,
hundreds and hundreds of microservices
now we have exploded cardinality there?
Is that where you need to see something?
Or is it slow database queries?
And again, we can see that
through the same setup,
traces, infrastructure monitoring metrics.
So we're looking at the
thing you need to see,
you need to recognize it,
you need to examine it.
Okay, now, once you get all
of that information together,
what do you do with it?
So this is like in that retro
that you have after the incident.
Once you say, "Was it caused
by a bug escaped defect
or was it caused because
we couldn't see it
so we couldn't fix it,
we couldn't get there in advance
of the customer sending us in a ticket
and saying, 'Hey, something's messed up.'"
This is the part that in an incident,
retro can get skipped,
can just be a line item, right?
It can be a, "We couldn't see it.
Assign the Jira."
Let's talk about not just can you see it,
but once we see it, what do we do with it?
(chuckles) If that alert
fires and you get woken up,
if there's no discussion on
what to do with that alert,
you're still back in
the same problem, right?
You're still tired, you're still confused.
So you might as well talk
about it in the retro
when you're awake and caffeinated
than in an incident in the
morning when that customer's mad.
So shaping is where you start
to leverage long-term thinking.
So in this case, a dashboard
is what these are from,
but there are ways to see
a limit versus traffic.
So I know what's happening,
I can boil down to who's doing it,
and now I can see what it's running into.
So okay, let's say a customer
is frustrated and that's their traces.
Okay?
Theoretically, it could
raise a limit a little bit
and give them some more.
Or you could look at that
and go, "Well, they're hitting
an endpoint or a rate limit
that they really shouldn't be.
Maybe they have a runaway integration
that limits doing what
it's supposed to be doing.
It's protecting them from more issues.
Do we need to lower the limit even more?"
And the last is test.
So this is outside of now that
retro that I talked about.
This is during, I don't know,
let's say a cleanup of your
backlog once a quarter.
Maybe once a month if
you wanna be proactive.
Is it working?
Are all those limits that I put in place,
not limits, sorry, all those
alerts that I put in place
or all the ways that I
now just spent money,
right, to see stuff, is it working?
Are these alerts going off
and they're meaningless?
Who's got a Slack channel
that's got a lot of alerts
that are meaningless?
It happens to all the time
if you don't iterate upon that process.
And it does take time, I get that,
and I'm sure all of us are
strapped for our own time.
But this is a way to keep costs down
is by going back and going,
"Well, we decided to ingest
100% of the logs for this service."
Well, did we actually need all of them?
Does it never fire? (chuckles)
Well, then maybe let's not
ingest 100% of the logs.
Let's take a step back
and change our ingest.
And we look at these things
through service-level
objectives or scorecards.
We go back and go, "What's our uptime?
Are we actually doing this?
Are we looking at the right stuff
so that we're engaging in the right places
and that we're preventing the
right things from happening?"
REST.
See, told you I'd get there.
Recognize, what's the
issue and who's impacted?
Examine, how do we see it?
shape, what do we do?
And then test, did it work?
And again, this is iterative.
So don't just do this once
and then walk away from it.
This is something that can be continually
a part of a conversation
that you're having
with your engineers during incidents
so that you can not only
help your customers,
but what I'll get to in a
second is keep cost down,
'cause that's a pretty important thing
for companies nowadays.
I mean, I know companies all the time,
but cost is is vector that
if you only talk about it
when a contract comes up for
renewal or every fiscal year,
it's blindsiding, right?
I mean, who's been in
meetings with, you know,
your finance team where they're like,
"Uh, you spent too much on
logs again, could you not?"
It's frustrating because now you're, like,
scrambling to get back to
a place that's sustainable.
But if you're continually having
conversations around that,
you're not stuck in those
conversations once a year
or once every three years or
whatever it ends up being.
We have this conversation
a lot more frequently than we used to.
We've been able to drive
down certain things
like query performance.
That's directly related to
infrastructure cost, right?
Queries perform better.
You lose less compute.
Save money.
Active datasets, same deal,
less to index means less
infrastructure cost.
You can move it to a
colder tier of storage.
But again, this is cost as a vector.
So you can do it, you can keep costs flat.
But it's a level of engagement that,
I don't wanna say it gets
lost, that's not fair,
but it's a level of engagement
that we didn't always do
in an iterative process
like we should have.
I've 100% had conversations
where a budget conversation comes up
and they're like, "You need how much?"
And that's a bad conversation to have
for everybody in the room.
There's executives who
are trying to balance
being able to let the
engineers see what they need to
to be able to do their job,
and there's a finance person
on the other end going,
"Well, but the industry standard is this."
But if, as an engineer,
you're engaged with a process
that iterates upon that,
that has conversation around not just,
"We need to see this," but,
"We need to see this,
here's how we should go about it."
We've managed that over the last few years
and it's really transformed
how we respond to incidents.
But how we continue to work through
new and emerging challenges
is because it's now a part of our DNA
because we have those
conversations continually.
Nobody's blindsided.
You're not waiting in
fear for the next time
you have that financial conversation
and that your observability
is gonna go away.
So let me talk a bunch
more about how we did that.
So hopefully I've set
the stage a little bit.
I've talked about the problem
that we have kind of all experienced.
but it's a clever acronym.
It's not necessarily actionable.
Let's talk about the actions
that go along with it.
So logs, this is kind of
where most people start,
most places start.
I think Zendesk started here as well.
Big, verbose logs.
Big, whack ton of JSON information, right?
Stuck in there
and then maybe formatted
depending on the UI you're using.
Datadog's UI formats are pretty well.
But they're big.
(chuckling) They're very expensive.
And do they actually give you
the information that you're looking for?
I mean, I was an advocate,
customer support at Zendesk Advocacy,
and I've looked at our
logs plenty of times.
I still look at our logs.
They're useful, but I don't
need every one of them.
I don't really care about
the successful request
that somebody sent to get
a help center article.
It worked! Not really relevant to me.
And we have audit trails if
we really need something.
Why would I record that?
Why would I even ingest that information?
It's a conversation worth having.
And again, part of that REST
is having that conversation,
testing, do you really
need that information?
You probably care more about
the 422 the customer's getting
because they're sending
you garbage payloads.
That's an issue that not
only customer support
can help resolve,
but it also could potentially
down the line cause incidents.
So you're managing things
like your ingest and your index pipeline.
Do we need to intake it?
How much does that cost?
Do we need to index it?
10%, 20%? Just the errors?
Again, it's different per company,
but if you don't have that conversation,
you just ship everything in
and you've got hundreds
of thousands of customers,
there's a lot of data,
and there's a lot of data you don't need.
The next is APM.
It's less expensive
tier, but you can tag it.
I showed you that graph
way back in the beginning,
that flame graph where it
had all of the little pieces
of the puzzle that were
happening on the call.
And this is where you can get at
traffic over time.
So let's say,
back to my example for
grabbing a help center article,
customer goes to help
center, gets an article,
retrieves it from the
database, perfect, 200.
Well, let's say they do
that 100,000 times a day.
Do we need all 100,000 of those,
or do I need 10% of those?
Again, your workflows are gonna vary,
but having that conversation
means you can go,
"Oh, well maybe we do
only need 10% of that."
Now, you can still see what's
happening to the customer.
They suddenly have a flood of requests
and you're called online.
You can still see it.
You don't see every single call,
but that every single
call wasn't important,
'cause we discussed that
in our testing part of REST.
The next is metrics.
So if I care
about all of the things
within my infrastructure
that are happening to,
let's say my EC2 instance,
one of my clusters, just for an example,
I don't need to see all
the customer information
to determine which one of
my hundreds of clusters
have high CPU load.
It's metric.
I can drill down into that.
I can decide that we need to do that
if we don't have the visibility
when something comes up.
But I don't need to plan for that.
I just need to plan for seeing
infrastructure on a high level.
That's perfect for what
metrics are used for.
Again, a less expensive
way to still be able
to see the things you need
when you're in that incident
and very frustrated.
And I've talked about this
kind of throughout this whole
index and ingest strategy
is cost lenses
and keeping that a part
of the conversation
as you move forward.
It's kind of uncomfortable, isn't it,
when you have those
conversations internally?
I'm not usually very comfortable
in finance conversations.
I'd rather avoid them.
Just give me a problem to solve
and I'm perfectly happy.
But if I can't see what I
need to see in the problem,
then solving the problem,
it is not just frustrating,
it's almost impossible.
So I've had to learn over time
that it's okay to have
those conversations.
It's okay to ask those questions.
And again, every
organization is different,
but developing that level
of openness within your organization
leads to huge dividends.
I mean, again, I showed you the evidence
of it a few slides ago.
There's no finance person
that is happier when they see
big flat line straight across for cost,
as long as that's underneath
the barrier that they set.
If it's over, then different problem.
But if you're having those conversations,
it's a lot less awkward.
So.
Need a quick drink.
It's a desert out here, quite literally.
So this is what we saw,
after, again, I said I've been at Zendesk
seven and a half years.
This isn't something
that happened overnight.
I'm showing this in a, what we saw now,
knowing all of the struggles
that we had getting up to here,
and I'll go into detail a little bit more
about those pitfalls in a minute.
But we saw a much faster response time.
Being able to get online,
to jump in an incident,
to see what's going on,
to have the alert fire to know exactly
what you're supposed to do with that alert
means a huge difference.
And because we can see
where that silly person
with the really loud stereo,
we know that they're in 21B,
we can put guardrails on them
to stop them affecting everybody else.
Soundproof the wall,
whatever you want to use for that analogy.
Or kick 'em out.
But we're also able to do things
that are on a much larger
infrastructure level
that by paying close attention
to being able to see
really granular parts
of our infrastructure
on the customer level,
we can rightsize things
like our cloud resources.
We can keep consistent EC2 instances
across our entire infrastructure,
and we can align our observability costs,
ingestion costs are aligned to the value
that they provide internally
and to our customers directly.
Speaking of customers,
we also have measurably happier customers.
Not every customer is happy,
that is the reality of the world,
but they are measurably happier
because we're responding to their issues
and getting them meaningful
information much faster.
I mean, we've all been on the
other end of incidents, right?
Like, we all of our
companies own or purchased
a piece of software from somebody else
and it's had an incident
and when it's the, "We're working on it
and we'll get back to you,"
30 minutes after they've been down,
is mind-bogglingly frustrating.
But if that company can see
better about what's going on,
they can be like, "Hey,
this part of our infrastructure
is having an issue.
Our engineers are working on it.
We'll get back to you soon."
It makes me feel so much better,
even though they've
still not done anything,
(chuckles) I still feel better
about it having that information.
So let me talk about the issues.
Don't do freeform tags. (chuckles)
Having any level of governance
over how you do observability internally
matters a huge amount for cost.
If everybody can just
put in what they want,
it can be the new teleteam
can be putting in for cookies
and the other team who's carrots
is looking at cookies as well,
but they called it cookies four,
it doesn't do anything.
You're looking at the same thing.
But because you tagged
it two different things,
now you're looking at it twice.
And more frustratingly
for the finance portion,
you're paying for it twice.
Might have done that.
It sucks.
And it's even worse to
untangle once it happens,
because if they're not
tagged consistently,
then how do you know that cookie
four is the same as cookie?
You've gotta get those teams together,
you gotta have a bunch of meetings,
and you gotta talk about it some more,
and then you gotta put a test in play.
You've all been there, I
don't need to go through it.
But, leads to high cost.
And the even trickier thing
is because it explodes cardinality,
it gives you a false sense of cardinality.
So it makes it look
like you need a lot more
observability on one layer
than you actually do,
because from the outside,
from, like, an SRE perspective,
my job, it looks like it's all different
and you don't know any
different just on the surface.
You gotta dig pretty deep.
So I said before
I was in customer support.
I loved catchall (laughs) logging.
It was an audit log and an
engineering log all in one place.
It is fricking expensive,
and to be honest, not
actually really worth it.
I'm sure there are workflows
out there that it is,
by the way.
For us it wasn't worth it.
And it means you're, like I said before,
in the freeform tags,
you're doubling, tripling,
quadrupling what you're recording,
'cause if you have now this
information in multiple places,
like you have it in logs
and then you have it in APM
and you built a metric around it
and you stuck your email
logs in, like, an S3 bucket,
well now you've paid for it four times,
and that's useless.
So having some governance
or some conversation around
how that stuff is used
keeps those index and
ingest levels correct.
So you can ingest a lot of
logs, depends on the platform,
or depends on the observability
of platform you're using,
but you can sometimes ingest logs,
costs very, very little,
'cause you're not spending any index time.
And that's a good way to
balance those two things out
is while I'm only indexing
the 400 range errors and
the 500 range errors,
and okay, for this one customer
who's had issues on this endpoint before,
I'm indexing those,
but the rest I'm ingesting.
I can go back and rehydrate if I need to,
but I'm not spending that cost upfront.
By the way, when that
went away for advocacy,
I was not happy.
But in the end,
it did really work out.
So there are some decisions you make
that will ruffle people's feathers.
That's the reality of
change for some people.
It's different and it's
a new thing to learn,
but it will be okay in the end.
As I said, having that conversation
and making sure that's a part of your DNA
at a certain point,
that really helped soften the blow here
across all of our customer support teams,
is being like, "Hey, cost
matters to our company.
(chuckling) We're here to
make money, not burn it,
and this is why we're doing that."
And that really did change the narrative
in a very meaningful way.
This one is hard, especially
for a big company,
but no owner map.
If I don't know
who is pumping all these logs in,
then whose desk do I sit at to go,
"Hey, could you not?"
Because if you just nuke
'em from outer space,
(chuckling) you will find
out really quick who it is,
what the problem is.
Again, you're gonna find out at 2:00 AM
when they jumped on for that incident.
And that leads
to customer frustration
and all these other things,
and, (sighs) again,
we've gone through all
that chain of events.
But having a service map,
having ownership over your service map
and making sure it's
continually up to date
is an extremely hard task,
but one of the more valuable tasks
that I have ever seen a company undertake.
I cannot tell you how nice it is
to be able to be in an incident,
look at a set of logs and go,
"I need to page this
team, under a minute."
There is no better feeling.
The worst feeling is when
you've paged 15 teams
and they're all in this Zoom
meeting yelling at each other
because you paged 15 wrong teams.
Now, everybody's off.
So again, hard
but extremely worth it in the end.
This last one, I alluded to it earlier,
but that Slack channel
where it's all these warnings and alerts
and nobody's reacting to any of them
because it's the same alert
that's been firing for
the last three weeks.
(sighs) Signal to noise
really matters in alerting,
and curating your alerts routinely,
I know, not all teams have time for that.
There's deadlines for
releases and there's deploys
and there's customer bugs
and all of these things.
I do get it.
I know this is kind of idealized
and doesn't always take
into account the real world,
but
it leads to a level of alert fatigue
that isn't just an issue for incidents.
It's that if everything's critical,
nothing's critical, right?
I mean, I think we've all heard
that phrase at some point.
It it ends up being that.
It's not that you're
just ignoring the alerts
that are flapping.
You start to ignore other
things that are also alerts
because in your head you're like,
"Well, I see this ping every five minutes
and it's pointless.
So now, other things might be pointless."
So it ends up like kind of
ballooning into an attitude
that changing the direction
of that ship can be difficult.
It ends up with issues ignored.
And again, back to my
customer experience days,
(chuckling) customers get really mad
when you ignore their issue.
And it's hard for an executive,
say big customer had an issue
they had to write in about,
you had a flapping alert
that told you about this issue,
but you ignored it because
it's always been flapping
or it was buried in
another flapping alert.
It's a really hard thing to
talk to a customer about.
It just is.
"Hey, we actually saw it two hours before,
but we can ignore it."
So that one's a hard one to curate
and I know it's hard to
make time to do that,
but it's another one that's really like,
it has a lot of cascading issues
other than just what it
seems like on the surface.
So you're all gonna leave here
in 20 minutes or so.
I want you to take away a couple things
because I did say a lot of things,
I showed up a lot of slides,
but I'd really love for you
to take away some of this
so you don't end up in some
of the pitfalls that we did.
They were frustrating,
we've come out of them,
but they're frustrating.
So start with a tag
before a fancy dashboard.
Figure out how you're
gonna record all this stuff
and stick to a standard.
Having a dashboard is nice,
but if you have no, like, rules,
no governance over those tags
that inform that dashboard,
you're doing style over substance
and that just,
it burns down quickly.
Invest early in per-tenant
KPI and heat maps.
I know that's really big
wording for a takeaway,
but if you're not talking
about performance on your tenants,
then you're gonna run into a scenario
where you can't focus resources
in an area appropriately.
You're gonna be kind of flailing.
And if you spend time early on,
this whole slide is
kind of about governance
and, like, company culture.
If you are investing in this early,
SLOs saying, "Hey,
my tickets endpoint,
they should be created in
three seconds or less."
Great.
Set an alert, set an SLO,
when it doesn't happen, talk about it,
because if you don't, you
end up hiding problems
because you're never looking
for them to begin with.
Treat cost as a first-class dimension.
I'm sure you're tired of me hearing,
or tired of me saying, you hearing,
the word cost over and over
and over and over again.
I get it. It gets old.
But without a culture
that is accepting of that,
it causes so many other issues,
like, I talked about that flapping alert,
like, it caused other cascading
and issues that kind
of go alongside of it.
Being afraid to talk about cost
can mean you are afraid to talk
about other big changes at the company
or big governances at the company.
Cost is a dimension for every
single company at some point.
And if teams internally aren't
comfortable talking about it,
how can you drive profitability?
How can you drive sustainability?
If everybody's scared of it,
it's really hard to do.
And the last is bake in context.
Essentially, fix your metadata.
(chuckles) If it's not
there, you can't see it.
And that goes back to the
REST that I talked about.
Iterating on a process,
whatever you want to call it,
I called it REST because
I get sleep deprived
and a groggy engineer needs rest.
But you can use whatever
mnemonic you want to use
or whatever process that works
within your company structure
to go through the process
and make it just a thing that you do.
"We are going to do REST today.
That's what we're gonna do."
Great. Everybody goes through and does it.
It's a great exercise.
But if you don't do that to
then bake in that tenant context
to then have it available
when that incident is called,
you're always reacting and
you're not being proactive.
And the thing customers love the most
is when you're ahead of the
issue before they even see it.
This is where you want to be, right?
Latency decreased, requests retained.
You want customers happy.
All of this that I just talked about
is all trying to drive those things.
Customers are how we make our money,
and if they're pissed,
they're gonna leave.
They're not gonna pay.
You're not gonna have a business.
So keeping customer context in mind
while it drives all of your
other observability decisions
is a really healthy balance to have.
Not saying it's easy.
But hopefully some of those
things are good takeaways
that you can use
to try to help drive those
conversations internally.
I know it's high and it's conceptual,
but I'm happy to give more
information around that.
I really appreciate you
all listening to me today
talk about this stuff.
Customer experience is
very near and dear to me.
It's a problem that always exists
and it's always there to solve
and I like solving problems.
I'm gonna open it up for
questions in a second.
If you have any that you want to ask
to the group, feel free.
But if you want to come to me afterwards
and don't want to talk in a big group,
I know not everybody's comfortable
with huge groups, feel free.
I'm more than happy to answer
any questions you might have
or if you need details on what we did.
I do want to give a huge, huge
thank you to Max from Datadog
who helped prepare this presentation
and to Zendesk as a whole
for giving me opportunity
to speak to everybody here today.
They are at booth 165.
There's my pitch.
(laughs) But yeah, I
appreciate all your time today.
Thank you so much.
(audience applauds)